This is such a C++ programmer thing to worry about. Because I used to worry about what to name things. Because in C++, C++ is a very paranoid language. Because you have to think about all the things that can go wrong on any given line of code. Like you could call the wrong function, or the type the thing gets instantiated with is we'll be missing something or we'll have the wrong thing in it. And so you have to take this very defensive stance when writing any C++ code. Now that I've been using Rust for a while now, I don't worry about these things at all.
这真是C++程序员才会担心的事情。因为我过去总是担心该给事物起什么名字。因为在C++中，C++是一种非常偏执的语言。因为你必须考虑代码中任何一行可能出错的地方。比如你可能会调用错误的函数，或者实例化该对象时所用的类型会缺少某些东西，或者里面包含了错误的东西。所以你在编写任何C++代码时都必须采取这种非常防御性的立场。现在我已经使用Rust一段时间了，我根本不用担心这些事情。
I don't worry about what to call things. I don't worry about how the code looks because I can be confident that it works. I don't have these problems just don't exist in Rust, I guess is what I'm saying. Welcome to ADSB the podcast episode 240 recorded on May 21st, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Jared Hobrock. This is part two of a four part interview. In this episode, we continue our conversation about thrust, rust versus C++, Python, NumPy, Numba and more.
我不用担心该怎么命名。我不用担心代码看起来怎么样，因为我可以确信它能正常工作。我想说的是，在Rust中，这些问题根本就不存在。欢迎收听ADSB播客第240期，录制于2025年5月21日。我是Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人Bryce一起采访Jared Hobrock。这是四部分采访中的第二部分。在这一集中，我们将继续讨论Thrust、Rust与C++、Python、NumPy、Numba等话题。
Pi, Numba, and more. I believe Bryce and I have a ton more questions to ask you on the roots of Thrust. I mean, I've been holding on to this question for a long time. The last time I was in New York, which was in April, we're recording this tail end of May, we got into a discussion of the different names for the OG name is iota from the I guess technically it was the C++ 11 standard but it comes from APL. Iota is a integer sequence where you increment by 1, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. In thrust there are two different names for this. There is the counting iterator and there is also the thrust sequence. And this has been up for much debate between Bryce and I of what is the correct name. But our first question is, do you recall,
Pi、Numba等等。我相信Bryce和我还有很多关于Thrust根源的问题要问你。我的意思是，这个问题我憋了很久了。上次我在纽约的时候，那是在四月，我们现在是在五月底录制，我们讨论了关于原始名称的不同叫法，即iota，我想从技术上讲它源自C++11标准，但它实际上来自APL。Iota是一个整数序列，你以1为增量，1、2、3、4、5、6。在Thrust中，对此有两个不同的名称。一个是counting iterator（计数迭代器），另一个是thrust sequence（序列）。关于什么是正确的名称，Bryce和我之间一直存在很多争论。但我们的第一个问题是，你还记得吗，
Jared, where the names for both thrust sequence as an algorithm and thrust counting iterator as a fancy iterator, do you recall where those came from? Sequence in particular, because it stands out. I think we were aware of iota and just like we couldn't name it, we couldn't give it that name. That is ridiculous. We were going to, you know, it's going to be used in every example. We can't use this stupid name that doesn't mean anything. So I think that's where sequence came from. And maybe we sort of justified it by saying, well, the interface isn't exactly the same, so we have to change the name. We can't
Jared，Thrust sequence作为一种算法，以及Thrust counting iterator作为一种花哨的迭代器，这两个名字你还记得是从哪里来的吗？特别是sequence，因为它很显眼。我想我们当时知道iota，只是我们无法给它命名，我们不能用那个名字。那太荒谬了。我们打算，你知道，它会被用在每一个示例中。我们不能用这个毫无意义的愚蠢名字。所以我认为这就是sequence的由来。也许我们通过说“嗯，接口不完全一样，所以我们必须改名”来为自己辩解。我们不能
use iota. And counting iterator, I think just came straight from boost. I think there was a boost counting iterator that we just took. If you want to talk about names, I can tell you the story of how Thrust got its name. Yeah, yes. I would love that story. Yes. So, uh, I think when I was working on it in grad school, maybe its name was STD Kuda, like, Stood Kuda, just as like a
使用iota。而counting iterator，我想直接来自Boost。我想有一个Boost counting iterator，我们直接拿来用了。如果你想谈谈名字，我可以告诉你Thrust是怎么得名的故事。太好了，我很想听听那个故事。是的。所以，我想当我在研究生院研究它时，它的名字可能是STD Kuda，就像Stood Kuda，只是作为一个
I don't know, a placeholder name. When I got to Nvidia, you know, maybe someone made the comment, it's not standard and it's not Kuda, so this is not a good name. So we said, okay, fine. And Nathan had just gotten back from a tour of Asia. So he had spent a few weeks touring Asia and touring like post-Soviet communist countries. And he had this picture of a Soviet worker from a mural or something like that. And I don't know, for some reason it appealed to him. And he
我不知道，一个占位符名称。当我来到Nvidia时，你知道，也许有人评论说，它既不是标准的，也不是Kuda，所以这不是一个好名字。所以我们说，好吧，没问题。而Nathan刚从亚洲巡回回来。所以他在亚洲和前苏联共产主义国家巡回了几周。他有一张来自壁画之类的苏联工人的照片。我不知道，出于某种原因，它吸引了他。然后他
decided we got to call this library Comrade, with a K, K-O-M-R-A-D-E. And we're going to use this picture I took as the avatar when we release it. I didn't really have a strong opinion about it. And I believe the, so for some reason he wanted to give the library a communist theme and he's not like a left-winger or anything like that. He just thought it was funny. And I remember the, so we released it on Google code under the name Comrad and the, the tagline was own the means of computation.
决定我们必须把这个库叫Comrade，用K开头，K-O-M-R-A-D-E。当我们发布它时，我们将使用我拍的这张照片作为头像。我对此并没有什么强烈的意见。我相信，出于某种原因，他想给这个库一个共产主义主题，他并不是什么左翼分子之类的。他只是觉得这很有趣。我记得，我们在Google Code上以Comrad的名字发布了它，标语是“拥有计算手段”。
And we're really proud of ourselves. We just released this library that we were really proud of. We gave it a hilarious name or so we thought. And then like the next day, we, after announcing that we've released this library to some mailing list at work, we get a response from someone who was very important and influential at the time at Nvidia saying that communism isn't cute, it isn't funny, you can't name it this. And so we were sort of shitting our pants because this guy is very important. We had to save face somehow and think about a different name. It was my
我们当时真的很为自己感到自豪。我们刚刚发布了这个让我们引以为豪的库。我们给它起了一个搞笑的名字，或者我们是这么认为的。然后第二天，在向公司内部的某个邮件列表宣布我们发布了这个库之后，我们收到了当时Nvidia一位非常重要且有影响力的人的回应，说共产主义并不可爱，也不好笑，你们不能这样命名。所以我们当时吓坏了，因为这家伙非常重要。我们必须以某种方式挽回面子，并考虑一个不同的名字。这是我的
task to come up with a new name after Nathan had failed and gotten us in trouble. What I did was I looked through every English word between four and six letters ending in ST. Since we were stealing everything else from Boost, we thought we would steal the name as well. So I saw Thrust and I said, how about Thrust? And originally I think people were like, Originally, I think people were like, you know, we were going from this, you know, left-wing tinge name to some sort of sexual innuendo for a name, but we stuck with it and somehow the name was stuck and now it's, you know, it's just firmly, firmly means this library's name and nothing else, but that's where the name came from. Just another thing we stole from Boost. I was going to say is I always thought that thrust and boost, like they share the same
任务，在Nathan失败并让我们陷入麻烦后，我想出一个新名字。我所做的是查看了所有四个到六个字母之间以ST结尾的英文单词。既然我们从Boost那里偷了其他所有东西，我们想我们也应该把名字也偷过来。所以我看到了Thrust，我说，Thrust怎么样？最初我想人们是这样想的，你知道，我们从这个带有左翼色彩的名字变成了一种带有性暗示的名字，但我们坚持了下来，不知何故这个名字就固定下来了，现在它，你知道，它就牢牢地、牢牢地代表了这个库的名字，没有别的意思，但这就是名字的由来。只是我们从Boost那里偷来的另一件事。我正想说，我一直认为Thrust和Boost，它们共享同一个
one syllable ST ending and that was intentional and it turns out that is the case. I had no idea. I had no idea that that was intentional. I knew about the guy wearing the thrust t-shirt, which we haven't mentioned until now. At one point, Bryce left the Microsoft Teams meeting to go and disappear and he came back with a Thrust t-shirt. I shouldn't say this for a variety of reasons, but I had these t-shirts made like right when I first started Nvidia And I believe that the only other person who has a thrust t-shirt is Jared because I think I gave you one
单音节ST结尾，这是故意的，事实证明确实如此。我完全不知道。我完全不知道那是故意的。我知道那个穿Thrust T恤的家伙，我们到现在还没提过。有一次，Bryce离开了Microsoft Teams会议，消失了，然后他穿着一件Thrust T恤回来了。出于各种原因我不应该说这个，但我是在刚开始Nvidia时让人制作了这些T恤，我相信除了我之外，唯一拥有Thrust T恤的人是Jared，因为我想我给了你一件
at like a committee meeting in 2018 or something, but I I I have like five of them made and I think I have like five of them made and I think like one of them got like faded in the wash and so I tossed it and I think I gave one to Jared and I guess I must have misplaced one because this is the only one that I have left. Yeah, they're collector's items now. Yeah. It is very sad because I can my my my what is it autistic tendencies or OCD can Tell me that it is the same logo that is misaligned the left or I guess Bryce's right side of the logo Is slightly thinner than the left side of the logo in?
在2018年左右的委员会会议上，但我让人做了五件，我想我让人做了五件，我想其中一件在洗涤时褪色了，所以我把它扔了，我想我给了Jared一件，我想我一定弄丢了一件，因为这是我剩下的唯一一件了。是的，它们现在是收藏品了。是的。这非常令人难过，因为我的，我的，我的，怎么说呢，自闭倾向或强迫症可以告诉我，这是同一个标志，但它对齐错误了，或者我猜Bryce标志的右侧比标志的左侧稍微细一点，在
one of the other painful things So the painful things I did with Thrust was one deal with the version control, two revitalize the docs twice, and then three I had to reconstruct this logo and I don't remember if I eventually, I think I may have gotten like some form of source image from Jared, but I remember there was something where like the fonts or something were missing and I ended up having to like, like I spent like a week on getting the the remade logo a little bit more correct. But then you know what I realized the other day was why didn't I fix it so that the thrust part fits all the way in the box?
其他痛苦的事情之一。所以我在Thrust上做的痛苦的事情是，第一处理版本控制，第二两次重振文档，然后第三我不得不重建这个标志，我不记得我是否最终，我想我可能从Jared那里得到了一些源图像，但我记得有些地方，比如字体之类的丢失了，我最终不得不，比如我花了一周时间让重做的标志更正确一些。但你知道我前几天意识到的是，为什么我没有修复它，让Thrust部分完全适合框内？
Like I got this S and this T out here, like even on the updated one, it's not all the way in there. So I'm so bummed at myself because I don't think I can push through another logo change. The real question is, I mean, thrust has within the name of it a programming language, aka Rust. I mean, which is our fantastic transition point to what is the future of parallel programming, parallel algorithm libraries. I mean, if you could restart today knowing everything, you know now I mean back when you were in the The genesis of what became thrust you didn't know about reductions
就像我把这个S和这个T放在外面，即使在更新的版本上，它也没有完全放进去。所以我对自己感到非常沮丧，因为我觉得我无法再推动另一次标志更改了。真正的问题是，我的意思是，Thrust的名字里包含了一种编程语言，也就是Rust。我的意思是，这是我们通往并行编程、并行算法库未来的绝佳过渡点。我的意思是，如果你今天能重新开始，了解你现在所知道的一切，我的意思是，当你处于Thrust起源的时候，你并不知道归约（reductions）
You grew into it and it's like looking back on it It it seems obvious that you would know that stuff, but you didn't at the time and and that is so true of like so many Things that they teach in not just computer science, but mathematics It's like like they teach you the artifact but they don't teach you the path to it and the path is very nonlinear. How would you if you were starting today like redesign a thrust library because you mentioned a couple times that you know it's kind of messy the internals. messy, the internals, and you don't need to divulge anything about your current work. But if you were doing thrust 2.0, maybe with a better name, with a better implementation, what would you do? Would it be in Rust? Would it be in C++?
你成长了，回首往事，似乎显而易见你会知道那些东西，但你当时并不知道，这对于计算机科学乃至数学中教授的许多事情来说都是如此。就像他们教你人工制品，但他们不教你通往它的路径，而路径是非常非线性的。如果你今天开始，你会如何重新设计Thrust库？因为你提到过几次，你知道它的内部结构有点乱。乱，内部结构，你不需要透露任何关于你目前工作的内容。但如果你在做Thrust 2.0，也许用一个更好的名字，更好的实现，你会怎么做？它会是Rust吗？它会是C++吗？
Tell all. I know what I would do. There's not a language, there's no current language that I think is sufficient, unfortunately. But there's three things that a language would need to do something like Thrust or just GPU parallelism really well. One is asynchronous. Thrust just fails at asynchrony for various reasons, but I'd start with a model for asynchrony. Hydrogeneity is important, by which I mean you really have to care about the fact that you're targeting more than one machine,
全说出来。我知道我会怎么做。不幸的是，我认为目前没有一种语言是足够的。但一种语言要做好像Thrust这样的事情，或者仅仅是GPU并行性，需要做三件事。一是异步。Thrust由于各种原因在异步方面失败了，但我会从一个异步模型开始。异构性很重要，我的意思是，你真的必须关心这样一个事实，即你的目标不仅仅是一台机器，
and they have different architectures, and the differences in the architectures matter. Even CUDA doesn't really have a good way to deal with this, unfortunately. And I base it all around tensors, not one-dimensional sequences. Tensors and multi dimensionality is sort of really important for parallelism. And it's important for sort of vital to everything that people do with GPUs, maybe aside from video games, I don't know how much tensors are important for video games, but everything else you do with a GPU involves tensors in some way.
它们有不同的架构，架构的差异很重要。不幸的是，即使是CUDA也没有很好的方法来处理这个问题。我把这一切都建立在张量（tensors）的基础上，而不是一维序列。张量和多维性对于并行性来说非常重要。而且对于人们用GPU所做的一切来说，这很重要，也许除了电子游戏，我不知道张量对电子游戏有多重要，但你用GPU做的其他一切都以某种方式涉及张量。
Even the implementation of Thrust today implicitly revolves around tensors, because you have these... I'm pretty sure the video games are just like, you know, one out of every 10 frame is real and the other nine are AI. So I think it's all just tensors these days. Yeah, I agree. But I think a good language for doing something with, for doing GPU parallelism really well would have to tackle at least those three things. And, you know, as I was saying, whenever you write a kuda kernel, you're implicitly doing tensor stuff, because every GPU is sort of shaped like a tensor in the architecture. So if you're doing something like a thrust reduce, whether you know
即使是今天Thrust的实现也隐含地围绕着张量，因为你有这些……我很确定电子游戏只是，你知道，每10帧中有一帧是真实的，其他九帧是AI。所以我认为这些天全是张量。是的，我同意。但我认为做GPU并行性做得很好的好语言至少必须解决这三件事。而且，正如我所说，每当你编写一个CUDA内核时，你都在隐含地做张量的事情，因为每个GPU在架构上都有点像张量。所以如果你在做像Thrust reduce这样的事情，无论你是否知道
it or not, when you take that input sequence, you have to sort of fold it into a shape that matches the shape of the hardware and inevitably that's some sort of multi-dimensional shape. So having a language where that was more explicit and can be taken advantage of would be really valuable for implementing libraries like Thrust. So those are some things I would do differently. I mean, there's a whole lot of problems with Thrust that are there for C++ reasons. And, you know, people have various different opinions on how to solve C++ problems, but really a better language would be better to work with. Unfortunately Rust is not that language.
它，当你获取该输入序列时，你必须将其折叠成与硬件形状相匹配的形状，不可避免地，那是一种多维形状。因此，拥有一种更明确且可以利用这一点的语言对于实现像Thrust这样的库将非常有价值。所以这些是我会做不同的事情。我的意思是，Thrust有很多问题是由于C++的原因而存在的。而且，你知道，人们对于如何解决C++问题有各种不同的看法，但实际上，一种更好的语言会更好用。不幸的是，Rust不是那种语言。
Rust, I write in Rust every day. I really like it. It's good for single threaded code, but I don't think it handles parallelism that well. And I don't think it knows what to do with GPU parallelism at all. It's sort of at odds with GPU parallelism, unfortunately. Interesting. Like the way that borrow checking works sort of assumes that you've got a single thread and it's going to call functions in sequential order and the borrow checker works really well when you're doing that but on a GPU we have a group
Rust，我每天都用Rust写代码。我真的很喜欢它。它对单线程代码很好，但我不认为它处理并行性很好。而且我不认为它知道如何处理GPU并行性。不幸的是，它与GPU并行性有点不一致。有趣。就像借用检查（borrow checking）的工作方式有点假设你有一个单线程，并且它将按顺序调用函数，而借用检查器在执行此操作时工作得非常好，但在GPU上我们有一组
of threads and they want to communicate and they maybe they want to mutate different parts of a shared array and no one knows how to make that work with the with barrow checking but what what if you don't program the threads and the parallelism directly what if the way that you express the parallelism is by like performing operations on arrays that get paralyzed. And then you're... Yeah, so... Yeah. So what if you just threw out mutation?
线程，它们想要通信，也许它们想要改变共享数组的不同部分，没有人知道如何让它与借用检查一起工作，但是如果你不直接编程线程和并行性呢？如果你表达并行性的方式是通过对被并行化的数组执行操作呢？然后你……是的，所以……是的。那么如果你抛弃突变（mutation）呢？
That's something you could do. Yeah, that's the other way to do it. Let's just not mutate the data or, you know, let's let the compiler decide how to parallelize collective operations on tensors or something like that. That's great. You don't need Rust for that. Rust assumes you're going to mutate very carefully and you're going to think very carefully about sharing, but if there's no sharing and there's no mutation, you don't need a borrow checker at all. Ah, that's an interesting point. That's a very interesting point. I had not considered that. That if you're in a purely value based world, like, why use Rust? Why not just there's dozens of options for that?
那是你可以做的事情。是的，那是另一种方法。让我们不要改变数据，或者，你知道，让我们让编译器决定如何并行化张量上的集体操作之类的。那太棒了。你不需要Rust来做那个。Rust假设你会非常小心地进行突变，并且你会非常仔细地考虑共享，但如果没有共享，也没有突变，你根本不需要借用检查器。啊，这是一个有趣的观点。这是一个非常有趣的观点。我没有考虑过这一点。如果你处于一个纯粹基于值的世界中，比如，为什么要用Rust？为什么不直接……有很多选择。
Yeah, we've got armies of people working on different MLIR dialects, right? Yes. So, we need to leverage those armies in a way that makes sense in a high-level language. At least, that's my opinion. And I would definitely start with just value semantics, just not necessarily functional, but like SSA sort of semantics. That's what MLIR gives you anyway. I think you could get really far with that,
是的，我们有大批人在研究不同的MLIR方言，对吧？是的。所以，我们需要以一种在高级语言中有意义的方式利用这些大军。至少，这是我的观点。我肯定会从值语义开始，不一定是函数式的，而是像SSA那样的语义。无论如何，这就是MLIR给你的。我认为你可以用它走得很远，
especially for the kinds of algorithms that are in Thrust. If you sort of assume that you have at your disposal operations that might look similar to what you would see in Cub, but they're sort of, instead of mutating arrays in a shared memory, you're instead just performing collective operations on values. You could easily build a thrust library, or a thrust-like algorithms like that.
特别是对于Thrust中的那些算法。如果你假设你拥有可能看起来类似于你在Cub中看到的那些操作，但它们是，而不是在共享内存中改变数组，你只是在对值执行集体操作。你可以很容易地构建一个Thrust库，或者像那样的Thrust类算法。
You just need a language to express it in. I guess another thing we need, one really bad thing about libraries like thrust or cub or cut lists is that they are locked in CUDA C++ templates, right? So to get access to them and reuse those implementations, you need to generate C++ templates, right? So to get access to them and reuse those implementations, you need to generate C++ code and then you need to find a C++ compiler to instantiate that code. Think about what we do from Python libraries that want to use the GPU.
你只需要一种语言来表达它。我想我们需要的另一件事，像Thrust或Cub或Cutlass这样的库的一个非常糟糕的事情是它们被锁定在CUDA C++模板中，对吧？所以要访问它们并重用这些实现，你需要生成C++模板，对吧？所以要访问它们并重用这些实现，你需要生成C++代码，然后你需要找到一个C++编译器来实例化该代码。想想我们从想要使用GPU的Python库中做了什么。
Inevitably, they generate some C++ code at runtime, compile it, and execute it. But what if, you know, they didn't have to do that, what if those implementations were in a more portable form than C++ templates? What if you didn't need a C++ compiler to use to get access to fast algorithms like, like Rincub, for example, that's something we need. So I guess the question is, what is preventing us from having the world that you are describing right now today? Obviously, Python, I think the three of us in this meeting can agree. And the folks that have the prerequisite knowledge to also agree with us can agree that Python is the non-ideal language for targeting GPUs.
不可避免地，它们在运行时生成一些C++代码，编译它，并执行它。但如果，你知道，它们不必那样做呢？如果这些实现以比C++模板更可移植的形式存在呢？如果你不需要C++编译器来访问像Rincub这样的快速算法呢，例如，那是我们需要的东西。所以我想问题是，是什么阻止了我们拥有你现在描述的世界？显然，Python，我想我们会议中的三个人可以同意。并且具备先决知识的人也同意我们，Python是针对GPU的非理想语言。
It's dynamic. Oh, no, I think I think I think I'll take a contrary perspective here. I think Python's great. I made this. I was for the first time ever. I've been on another podcast, the Talk Python Python to me podcast and I made this point that I will claim that Python is actually a performance oriented language and the reason for this is that Python has very loosey goosey semantics it's a very flexible language and it does not have a ton of rigorous protocol when interfacing with other languages.
它是动态的。哦，不，我想我想我会在这里持相反的观点。我认为Python很棒。我做了这个。我第一次，我参加了另一个播客，Talk Python to me播客，我提出了这一点，我声称Python实际上是一种面向性能的语言，原因在于Python具有非常宽松的语义，它是一种非常灵活的语言，并且在与其他语言交互时没有大量的严格协议。
And it's very easy to build a DSL in Python. It's very easy to build something that takes Python syntax and kind of Python semantics and lower it down to native code. And it's also very easy for Python to call into native code. I remember a few years ago, I went to this conference at Facebook, this was back when I was in California. And there was this fellow who was a very senior JVM engineer.
而且在Python中构建DSL非常容易。构建一些采用Python语法和某种Python语义并将其降低到原生代码的东西非常容易。而且Python调用原生代码也非常容易。我记得几年前，我去Facebook参加了这个会议，那是我在加利福尼亚的时候。有一个家伙，他是一位非常资深的JVM工程师。
And he was talking about, he gave a 30 minute talk solely on all the work that they had to do to make JVM native calls fast. And the reason that they had to do all this work, it was like the calling convention for JVM, the call native code, was like at minimum 100 instructions. Because the JVM had these very very specific you know protocols for like you know relating to like object semantics and
他正在谈论，他做了30分钟的演讲，专门讲他们为了使JVM原生调用变快而必须做的所有工作。他们必须做所有这些工作的原因是，JVM的调用约定，调用原生代码，至少需要100条指令。因为JVM有这些非常非常具体的，你知道，协议，比如，你知道，涉及对象语义，
you had to you had to follow all these rules whereas like in Python it can just be like oh you just you just call this function you just call this function you know and like yeah maybe though like if you want to have like two-way interop like maybe the function needs to like use some of the Python APIs but like it's super simple in Python to just call a C function. That makes it easy for Python to call into fast things. Also on top of that, it's easy to extend to Python to build DSLs for Python. Because of that, I think of Python as being more a performance-oriented language.
你必须遵循所有这些规则，而在Python中，它可以只是，哦，你只是调用这个函数，你只是调用这个函数，你知道，就像，是的，也许虽然，如果你想有双向互操作，也许函数需要使用一些Python API，但就像在Python中调用C函数超级简单。这使得Python很容易调用快速的东西。此外，扩展Python以构建Python的DSL也很容易。正因为如此，我认为Python更像是一种面向性能的语言。
I think Python's more similar to C++ and Rust in that it is used, I would say, maybe not predominantly, but certainly it's getting closer and closer to that point where Python is predominantly used for performance oriented tasks like machine learning and data science. I've heard you say this three times now that Python is performance oriented and I literally thought the first time you said it I was going to be like oh he said it one time I won't be able to call him out on it. You said that three times. Are you serious?
我认为Python更类似于C++和Rust，因为它被使用，我会说，也许不是主要的，但肯定它越来越接近这一点，即Python主要用于面向性能的任务，如机器学习和数据科学。我已经听你说了三次了，Python是面向性能的，我真的以为你第一次说的时候，我会说，哦，他说了一次，我无法反驳他。你说了三次。你是认真的吗？
I am serious. Hey we have free threading now. It's all going to be fast. It's going to be very fast. Jared do you can you back me up? What are we talking about here a non compiled? dynamic interpreted language that treats integers as
我是认真的。嘿，我们现在有自由线程了。一切都会很快。它会非常快。Jared，你能支持我吗？我们在谈论什么，一种非编译的？动态解释语言，将整数视为
Objects what are we talking about here Bryce? What are we talking about here? But the point is that that in the places where you care about performance you can use it yet Like if you if you write wait wait, wait, wait. You just said it was performance oriented and now you're saying in the places where you care you can use it. It treats integers as opt in the base language. Like if you want performance, it's better to use numpy instead of the baked in lists to Python. Like as soon as you're over a thousand... Not if you're using JIT. What do you mean JIT? One second, one second. I'm pulling up some... The reason Bryce can say this is because Python has had...Python is backed by Google and has
对象，我们在谈论什么，Bryce？我们在谈论什么？但重点是，在你在乎性能的地方，你可以使用它。就像如果你写，等等，等等，等等。你刚才说它是面向性能的，现在你说在你在乎的地方你可以使用它。它在基础语言中将整数视为对象。就像如果你想要性能，最好使用NumPy而不是Python内置的列表。就像一旦你超过一千……如果你使用JIT则不然。你说的JIT是什么意思？等一下，等一下。我正在调出一些……Bryce能这么说的原因是Python有……Python有Google支持，并且
been for the past 20 years and Google is the ones that have been paying to make all of these libraries fast through Python, right? But as soon as you need to do something that one of these libraries doesn't have a C API for, you're screwed, right? Exactly. That is true. Exactly. And that's the thing is that in general, if you...
在过去的20年里一直如此，而Google是那些一直付费通过Python使所有这些库变快的人，对吧？但一旦你需要做一些这些库没有C API的事情，你就完蛋了，对吧？完全正确。那是真的。完全正确。这就是重点，通常，如果你……
I've said this before on the podcast that if you want performant code in Python, you shouldn't use Python, you should use NumPy because NumPy is implemented in C and as soon as you're doing anything serious, and by serious I mean greater than 1000 elements in a list, it's faster just in any library that's dispatching to C code, which means how is Python performance oriented?
我之前在播客上说过，如果你想要Python中的高性能代码，你不应该使用Python，你应该使用NumPy，因为NumPy是用C实现的，一旦你做任何严肃的事情，我说的严肃是指列表中超过1000个元素，它在任何调度到C代码的库中都更快，这意味着Python怎么是面向性能的？
That means that Python is a language that facilitates fast libraries that are not actually in Python. Yes, that is true, but also Python has a number of different JIT options that are very good. So this is like we use Numba as the basis of our like CUDA Python device code authoring. And so you can write kernels in CUDA Python that will compile down to the same machine code that you would get if you wrote them in CUDA C++. And you can use abstractions like lists, like you can use all the Pythonic things in this code
这意味着Python是一种促进快速库的语言，这些库实际上并不在Python中。是的，那是真的，但Python也有许多不同的JIT选项，它们非常好。所以这就像我们使用Numba作为我们CUDA Python设备代码创作的基础。所以你可以在CUDA Python中编写内核，这些内核将编译成与你用CUDA C++编写它们时得到的相同的机器代码。你可以在此代码中使用抽象，比如列表，你可以使用所有Python的东西
because it's just this like little DSL that is, Numba's gonna kind of violate some of the object semantics. You're not gonna have an interpreter. You're not gonna have object lifetimes. It's gonna map everything down to value semantic things in the C++ machine model. And you'll get the same perf. And now you can even use our device side libraries
因为这只是这个小小的DSL，Numba会有点违反一些对象语义。你不会有一个解释器。你不会有对象生命周期。它会将一切映射到C++机器模型中的值语义事物。并且你会得到相同的性能。现在你甚至可以使用我们的设备端库
in something like Numbakuda. So like, yeah, like Python, like on its face is like, you know, can be pretty slow, but Python gives you all the tools to make it very, very fast. And- Right, so you're talking about publicly about how it works? Or is that not publicly acknowledged?
在像Numbakuda这样的东西中。所以，是的，Python，表面上看起来，你知道，可能相当慢，但Python给了你所有让它变得非常非常快的工具。而且——对，所以你在公开谈论它是如何工作的？还是那不是公开承认的？
It's all open source. It's all open source, because Numba is just an open source JIT compiler. So what Numba does is it just takes either Python bytecode or AST, and then it lowers it down to this IR called Numba IR. And then all that Numba IR is used for is to do type inference to figure out hey you're calling this function here you know what are all the types and then once you have all the types resolved you'd lower it down to either LLVMIR
它是开源的。它是开源的，因为Numba只是一个开源的JIT编译器。所以Numba所做的是它只是获取Python字节码或AST，然后它将其降低到这个称为Numba IR的IR。然后所有这些Numba IR被用来做类型推断，以弄清楚嘿，你在这里调用这个函数，你知道，所有的类型是什么，一旦你解析了所有的类型，你就会将其降低到LLVM IR
or MLIR and then it compiles just like it would native code and there's like two or three like major JIT solutions like this for Python. And, you know, the best analogy I can give is like JavaScript. So JavaScript is another language which JITs very, very well. You can write code in JavaScript which after it's been JIT, has performance that is close to the performance of native code. You can't do that with a language like Java, which has a very rigorous object model that makes it very challenging to really
或MLIR，然后它就像原生代码一样编译，并且Python有两三个像这样的主要JIT解决方案。而且，你知道，我能给出的最好的类比是JavaScript。所以JavaScript是另一种JIT非常非常好的语言。你可以用JavaScript编写代码，在它被JIT之后，其性能接近原生代码的性能。你不能用像Java这样的语言做到这一点，它有一个非常严格的对象模型，使得真正
be able to do that. But with languages like JavaScript and Python, their object models are a really good fit. And in particular, if you're writing this like NumPy type code, like when it lowers things down, if it sees lists, lists get lowered down to just like an aggregate type, the equivalent of like a std tuple. You know, integers, floats, etc., when they get compiled, they're just going to be lowered down to the equivalent native processor types. And something like a NumPy array is just going to be lowered down to like a pointer plus
能够做到这一点非常具有挑战性。但对于像JavaScript和Python这样的语言，它们的对象模型非常合适。特别是，如果你在编写这种NumPy类型的代码，就像当它降低事物时，如果它看到列表，列表会被降低到仅仅是一个聚合类型，相当于std tuple。你知道，整数、浮点数等，当它们被编译时，它们只是会被降低到等效的原生处理器类型。而像NumPy数组这样的东西只是会被降低到像指针加
a metadata, the equivalent of like an MD span. And something like a NumPy array is just going to be lowered down to like a pointer plus some metadata. You know, the equivalent of like an MD span. But yeah, like NumPy, it just goes, takes your DSL, takes your Python AST or your Python bytecode, turns it into this intermediate IR and it does the typing and then it becomes LVM IR or MLIR and number is like the heaviest weight of the Python DSL compilers there's also a lot of other DSL compilers there's some that do transpilation so they take Python code they turn it into C++ this is actually what Kupai does Kupai takes your Python code and it turns it into like it'll it'll spit out like thrust or cub code and then it'll get compile that code and then there's other compilers that will use an approach called tracing where instead of
一个元数据，相当于MD span。而像NumPy数组这样的东西只是会被降低到像指针加一些元数据。你知道，相当于MD span。但是，是的，NumPy，它只是去，获取你的DSL，获取你的Python AST或你的Python字节码，将其变成这个中间IR，它进行类型化，然后它变成LLVM IR或MLIR，Numba是Python DSL编译器中最重量级的，还有很多其他的DSL编译器，有些做转译，所以它们获取Python代码，它们将其变成C++，这实际上是Kupai所做的，Kupai获取你的Python代码，它将其变成，比如它会吐出Thrust或Cub代码，然后它会编译该代码，然后还有其他编译器会使用一种称为跟踪（tracing）的方法，而不是
like parsing the Python AST they essentially just inject mock objects into your code and then as your code executes instead of doing whatever your code was supposed to do it captures a trace and it builds up like from your actual code execution it builds up a representation of your program and then they transform that and they lower it down in whatever way this is how like things like Triton used to work although I think they now have a more proper compiler framework but there's a ton of these different tracing frameworks. One problem that we have at NVIDIA is that it's so easy to make DSLs in Python that we have like 20 DSLs in Python.
像解析Python AST那样，它们本质上只是将模拟对象注入到你的代码中，然后当你的代码执行时，它不是做你的代码应该做的任何事情，它捕获一个跟踪，并建立，比如从你的实际代码执行中，它建立你的程序的表示，然后它们转换它并以任何方式降低它，这就是像Triton这样的东西过去工作的方式，尽管我认为它们现在有了一个更合适的编译器框架，但有大量的这些不同的跟踪框架。我们在NVIDIA面临的一个问题是，在Python中制作DSL太容易了，以至于我们有大约20个Python DSL。
Every two to three weeks, somebody's creating a new Python DSL. Yeah, but what if you need to write a kernel? Like none of these approaches have anything to offer. Yeah, yeah, they do. You can totally write kernels in a... You can't write kernels really in Python. Yeah, yeah, you have access to all the tools that you have in access to. No one serious is writing kernels in Python.
每两到三周，就有人在创建一个新的Python DSL。是的，但如果你需要编写一个内核呢？这些方法都没有提供任何东西。是的，是的，它们有。你完全可以在……中编写内核。你不能真的在Python中编写内核。是的，是的，你有权访问你拥有的所有工具。没有严肃的人在Python中编写内核。
I'm telling you... Then why isn't Th kernels in Python. I'm telling you. Then why isn't Thrust written in Python? We could get there. So this is like a Speed of Light softmax kernel written in native Python. You can allocate showed memory. You can allocate register memory. You can use cub. You can use showed memory, you can allocate register memory, you can use cub, you can use like other libraries too. Like people are starting to use this. People are starting to write like serious kernels.
我告诉你……那为什么Thrust内核不是用Python写的。我告诉你。那为什么Thrust不是用Python写的？我们可以达到那个目标。所以这是一个用原生Python编写的Speed of Light softmax内核。你可以分配共享内存。你可以分配寄存器内存。你可以使用Cub。你可以使用共享内存，你可以分配寄存器内存，你可以使用Cub，你也可以使用其他库。就像人们开始使用这个了。人们开始编写像严肃的内核。
Why is it good for a kernel to look like that? Because one, you get to do, you get to use NumPy style arrays. Like the Python has like de facto very nice... Rank polymorphism. Would you care to elaborate on that, sir? You're saying NumPy like arrays, but the word is rank polymorphism. Like that's the thing that Jerob was saying is if he was gonna do it over again, he would implement it in terms of tensors.
为什么内核看起来那样是好的？因为第一，你可以做，你可以使用NumPy风格的数组。就像Python有非常好的……秩多态性（Rank polymorphism）。你想详细说明一下吗，先生？你说NumPy风格的数组，但这个词是秩多态性。就像那是Jared刚才说的，如果他要重做，他会用张量来实现它。
When you're implementing something in terms of tensors, it means if you have a two dimensional or three dimensional array, you don't have to spell map, map, map in order to do an element wise operation over your arbitrarily ranked array. NumPy semantics is array language semantics. It means that if you want to do some element-wise operation, it's just a single character plus a scalar or something like that. So that is one of the benefits of NumPy, which is a poorly implemented array language, is rank polymorphism or broadcasting.
当你用张量来实现某事时，这意味着如果你有一个二维或三维数组，你不必拼写map、map、map来对你的任意秩数组执行元素级操作。NumPy语义是数组语言语义。这意味着如果你想做一些元素级操作，它只是一个字符加一个标量之类的。所以这就是NumPy的好处之一，它是一种实现得很差的数组语言，即秩多态性或广播（broadcasting）。
And this isn't even to mention the very cool thing that we announced at GTC this year, which is Kutile, which is a new higher level programming model for CUDA that's entirely array based, where you don't explicitly program threads. And like this is what the speed of light softmax looks like in Kutile. And on like on the left, you're seeing the NumPy code and on the right, you're seeing the Kutile code and they're very close and it's using taking advantage of the rank polymorphous and the kind of talking about but to get to the question why would you want to write a kernel from Python well it is a very
这甚至还没提到我们在今年GTC上宣布的非常酷的事情，即Kutile，这是一种新的CUDA高级编程模型，完全基于数组，你不需要显式编程线程。就像这就是Kutile中Speed of Light softmax的样子。在左边，你看到NumPy代码，在右边，你看到Kutile代码，它们非常接近，并且它正在利用秩多态性和那种谈论，但要回答为什么你想从Python编写内核的问题，嗯，有一个非常
simple answer to that question which is if you can write the kernel in Python then you don't have to deal with having to support both C++ and Python in your application. Then you don't have to deal with having a C++ build system and it solves a bunch of packaging problems for you because instead of having to build a Python extension or a shared library that Python loads, you can just ship Python source code, which is what most Python projects do. So it saves a lot of headache that people have. Sure. I'm not here to defend C++.
简单的答案，那就是如果你可以用Python编写内核，那么你就不必处理在你的应用程序中同时支持C++和Python的问题。那么你就不必处理拥有C++构建系统的问题，它为你解决了一堆打包问题，因为你不必构建Python扩展或Python加载的共享库，你只需要发布Python源代码，这是大多数Python项目所做的。所以它节省了人们面临的很多麻烦。当然。我不是来为C++辩护的。
I'm just defending the idea of an ideal. What is the platonic ideal of GP programming language? I wouldn't begin with Python, I guess is what I'm saying. I understand people have, people like Python and they have requirements to use Python. I just like to imagine what the perfect GPU language would look like. I would agree, and the reason I would agree is that
我只是在捍卫一种理想的想法。什么是GPU编程语言的柏拉图式理想？我想我不会从Python开始，我想这就是我想说的。我理解人们有，人们喜欢Python，并且他们有使用Python的要求。我只是喜欢想象完美的GPU语言会是什么样子。我会同意，我同意的原因是
there are, well, I think that the NumPy ecosystem and its prevalence in Python is a huge improvement over C++. Having these like rank polymorphic arrays that are, it's a vocabulary type. It's not like part of the language, but it's in such wide usage that like every library that does anything with tensors supports the NumPy semantics. And that's great. However, NumPy is a little bit old, 20, 30 years old, and it does have like a number of words to it. One of the things...
有，嗯，我认为NumPy生态系统及其在Python中的流行是对C++的巨大改进。拥有这些像秩多态数组，它是一种词汇类型。它不是语言的一部分，但它被如此广泛地使用，以至于每个处理张量的库都支持NumPy语义。这太棒了。然而，NumPy有点老了，20、30岁了，它确实有一些词汇。其中一件事……
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Let's back up. Python is 30 years old, not NumPy. You're getting your languages and your libraries confused. Python was created in 1993 or 94. NumPy was not. When was Num Numpy created? Numpy, I think it became popular around 2010. And I agree completely with Jared. Like if I'm designing a GPU language from scratch, I'm not starting anywhere close to Python. The fact that Python has become the lingua franca of in 2005.
哇，哇，哇，哇。让我们退后一步。Python是30岁，不是NumPy。你把你的语言和你的库搞混了。Python创建于1993或94年。NumPy不是。NumPy是什么时候创建的？NumPy，我想它在2010年左右变得流行。我完全同意Jared的观点。就像如果我从头开始设计一种GPU语言，我不会从任何接近Python的地方开始。事实上，Python已经成为通用语，在2005年。
But yeah, Travis Ollifont was someone I I hope to it was 20 years ago I said 20 years that is I 50 no no no you said 30 30 was the genesis of Python dinner with or we were at the same the same dinner table at the pilot ease charity auction with with Travis all of us last week very nice fellow fantastic fantastic my point being is that I agree with Jared. Python was created 30 years ago, numpy halfway through the lifetime of Python, and a dynamically quasi-strongly typed language with all this great FFI.
但是，是的，Travis Ollifont是我希望……那是20年前，我说20年，那是……我50……不，不，不，你说30，30是Python的起源，晚餐，或者我们在同一个晚餐桌上，在Pilot Ease慈善拍卖会上，和Travis Ollifont，我们上周，非常好的家伙，太棒了，太棒了，我的观点是我同意Jared。Python创建于30年前，NumPy在Python生命周期的一半，一种动态准强类型语言，带有所有这些伟大的FFI。
That's not, the reason that Python today is the language that folks use to target GPUs is not because it's a good language for targeting GPUs. It is okay, but it's not where I would start. And that's, I think that's what Jared was trying to say is that it, I think Python gets in the way of what we would like from a language in terms of trying to eke out max efficiency
那不是，今天Python成为人们用来针对GPU的语言的原因不是因为它是一种针对GPU的好语言。它还可以，但它不是我会开始的地方。而且，我想这就是Jared试图说的，它，我认为Python阻碍了我们从语言中想要的，试图榨取最大效率
and performance from GPUs. And it's just an artifact of history that it's become the lingua franca of data science and machine learning and deep learning, et cetera. I don't know. Maybe Jared, you could add if you disagree with what I just said. When I, so I picked up Python recently
和GPU的性能。它只是历史的产物，它成为了数据科学和机器学习、深度学习等的通用语。我不知道。也许Jared，如果你不同意我刚才说的，你可以补充。当我，所以我最近捡起了Python
because I was considering using it for a project and whenever I use Python, I feel like I've lost, like I've gone blind, like I've lost a sense because there are no types. And even when there are types, they're not really there, right? Like they don't do anything for you. So I feel like, I mean, even if you use the type descriptions, they don't, they're not
因为我正在考虑将其用于一个项目，每当我使用Python时，我觉得我失去了，就像我失明了，就像我失去了一种感觉，因为没有类型。即使有类型，它们也不是真的在那里，对吧？就像它们对你没有任何作用。所以我感觉，我的意思是，即使你使用类型描述，它们也不，它们不是
helpful. So I don't know, I just feel like I have brain damage or something when I'm writing or reading or writing Python code. I like Rust because once a cargo check is happy with the program, I'm confident it's going to work. I can do enormous refactors to a code base and be confident that they were correct. And nothing like that is possible with Python. I know it's important. I know it's probably the most important programming language,
有帮助的。所以我不知道，我只是觉得我在编写或阅读或编写Python代码时大脑受损了。我喜欢Rust，因为一旦cargo check对程序满意，我就确信它会工作。我可以对代码库进行巨大的重构，并确信它们是正确的。Python不可能做到这一点。我知道这很重要。我知道它可能是最重要的编程语言，
but there are some things that Python is inadequate for. There's a particular wort of NumPy that I want to highlight. If I highlight that wort, it rapidly leads into the really cool algorithm that I want to show you. And I suspect that Connor may have a couple, a couple of topics he wants to discuss with Jared before we get there. So no, no, I mean, we can go down this rabbit hole. I would just like to go on record saying that Python is the most popular language in the
但有些事情Python是无法胜任的。我想强调NumPy的一个特定部分。如果我强调那个部分，它很快就会引出我想向你们展示的那个非常酷的算法。我怀疑Connor在我们要讲到那里之前，可能还有几个他想和Jared讨论的话题。所以不，我的意思是，我们可以深入探讨这个问题。我只想郑重声明，Python是目前最流行的语言，
world at the time that LLMs have come of age Which makes you think that the rich are just gonna get richer. I am willing to bet my life on the fact that Python will not be the actual language that LLMs target because it's it's not a language like Rust that is statically typed has more linting etc is Better to target than a dynamically typed language. And so anyways, I'm just going on record saying Python is popular now and will die before I die. And that's also keeping in mind
在LLM（大语言模型）成熟的时代。这让你觉得富人只会变得更富。我敢拿我的生命打赌，Python不会是LLM真正瞄准的语言，因为它不像Rust那样是静态类型的，有更多的代码检查等，比动态类型语言更适合作为目标。总之，我只是郑重声明，Python现在很流行，但在我死之前它就会消亡。而且还要考虑到
that I will upload my brain to the cloud and live forever, at which point we will now transition to Bryce's segue into his algorithm that he wants to talk about. So before we get there, a quick thing on LLMs. So I've been thinking a little bit recently about this question about what language will the LLMs write code in. And one thing that's come up is this question of coding conventions. In particular, what coding conventions should we as programmers follow to make it easier
我会把我的大脑上传到云端并永生，届时我们将过渡到Bryce关于他想谈论的算法的衔接。所以在我们讲到那里之前，先简单说一下LLM。最近我一直在思考一个问题，即LLM会用什么语言编写代码。其中一个出现的问题是关于编码规范。特别是，作为程序员，我们应该遵循什么样的编码规范，以便更容易
to use LLMs in our code bases? And one particular piece of this that's come to mind to me has been around naming conventions. I think typically, at least me, I tend to prefer, earlier in my career I would use very long and verbose names. But now I primarily write code for slides and I've got a limited number of characters that I can use in the slide. And so I've found myself using shorter and shorter names as my career goes on. But it seems to me like you probably want to use quite descriptive names in your code base if you're planning on using LLMs to help you write your code. Maybe even you want to use
在我们的代码库中使用LLM？其中一个我想到的部分是关于命名规范。我认为通常情况下，至少对我来说，我倾向于——在我职业生涯早期，我会使用非常长且冗长的名称。但现在我主要为幻灯片编写代码，我在幻灯片中可以使用的字符数量有限。所以随着职业生涯的发展，我发现自己使用的名称越来越短。但对我来说，如果你打算使用LLM来帮助你编写代码，你可能需要在代码库中使用相当具有描述性的名称。甚至你可能想使用
names that are you know more verbose than would be comfortable for a human. Because that's like, if you use very short names that could be ambiguous or misinterpreted, it might be more confusing to the OOM. Whereas if you use very clear and concise names that are unambiguous, that's going to probably give you better results with using OOMs. This is such a C++ programmer thing to worry about. probably give you better results with using LLMs. This is such a C++ programmer thing to worry about. Because I used to worry about what to name things.
比人类习惯的更冗长的名称。因为如果你使用非常短的名称，可能会产生歧义或被误解，这可能会让LLM感到困惑。而如果你使用非常清晰、简洁且无歧义的名称，这可能会让你在使用LLM时获得更好的结果。这真是C++程序员才会担心的事情。可能会让你在使用LLM时获得更好的结果。这真是C++程序员才会担心的事情。因为我过去常常担心该如何命名事物。
Because in C++, C++ is a very paranoid language. Because you have to think about all the things that can go wrong on any given line of code. Like you could call the wrong function or the type the thing gets instantiated with will be missing something or will have the wrong thing in it. So you have to take this very defensive stance when writing any C++ code. Now that I've been using Rust for a while now, I don't worry about these things at all. I don't worry about what to call things. I don't worry about how the code looks because
因为在C++中，C++是一种非常偏执的语言。因为你必须考虑任何一行代码中可能出错的所有事情。比如你可能会调用错误的函数，或者实例化该事物时类型会缺少某些东西，或者里面有错误的东西。所以你在编写任何C++代码时都必须采取这种非常防御性的立场。现在我已经使用Rust一段时间了，我根本不用担心这些事情。我不用担心该如何命名事物。我不用担心代码看起来怎么样，因为
I can be confident that it works. These problems just don't exist in Rust, I guess is what I'm saying. These things I used to get paranoid about in my T++ template codes, there's usually only one right way to write the Rust function according to some LLM. And if it compiles, then it's correct. And you move on. These ambiguities just simply don't exist. It's a very relaxing way to write code.
我可以确信它能正常工作。我想说的是，这些问题在Rust中根本不存在。我过去在C++模板代码中担心的这些事情，根据某些LLM的说法，通常只有一种正确的方法来编写Rust函数。如果它能编译通过，那么它就是正确的。然后你就可以继续了。这些歧义根本不存在。这是一种非常轻松的编写代码的方式。
And I can echo that. When you write Rust code, I am more of an expert in C++ than I am in Rust by two orders of magnitude. Like I've written a couple thousand lines of Rust. That doesn't make me an expert, but like I know the inner details of the special member functions and all this stuff.
我对此深有同感。当你编写Rust代码时，我在C++方面的专家程度比在Rust方面高出两个数量级。比如我写过几千行Rust代码。这并不能让我成为专家，但我了解特殊成员函数的所有内部细节以及所有这些东西。
And I have so much like cognitive weight in my brain when I program C++ and I'm like, oh, I gotta, am I using an initializer list? Well, I've got a special set of rules for that. And it's just like, I have all these voices talking in my head when I program in C++. When I go to Rust, I'm kind of just like, I don't really know what's happening here,
当我在编写C++程序时，我的大脑承受着巨大的认知负担，我会想，哦，我必须，我是在使用初始化列表吗？好吧，我有一套特殊的规则。就像我在编写C++程序时，脑子里有各种声音在说话。当我转向Rust时，我有点像，我真的不知道这里发生了什么，
but the compiler like holds your hand and is like, don't worry, I'll be the expert. You just program the way you want to program. And all I'm saying is, the future of generated code targets a language like that. Not like C++ where you have a matrix of special member functions where depending on the subset that you implemented, you will get a certain other set generated. It's anyway, so I mean, and that's C++. You're trying to say that Python, dynamically typed,
但编译器会像牵着你的手一样说，别担心，我会成为专家。你只需要按照你想要的方式编写程序。我只想说，生成式代码的未来目标是像那样的语言。而不是像C++那样，你有一个特殊成员函数的矩阵，根据你实现的子集，你会得到一组特定的其他生成函数。总之，我是说，那是C++。你是想说Python，动态类型，
et cetera, et cetera language is gonna be the, no, it's in the short term, that's what's gonna happen. In the long term, the more compiler up front, static analysis guarantees that you can get. That's what's gonna be the future, in my opinion. But Bryce has a story to tell us about some algorithm and potentially refuting everything we're saying here. So we'll let Bryce speak now and convince us.
等等，等等的语言会成为……不，在短期内，这确实会发生。从长远来看，你能够获得越多的编译器前期静态分析保证。在我看来，这就是未来。但Bryce有一个关于某种算法的故事要告诉我们，并且可能反驳我们在这里所说的一切。所以我们现在让Bryce发言，说服我们。
Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在adspthepodcast.com上，以获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。